this election continues to grow more and
more contentious
especially i think that is worth noting
that the the
there seems to be a widespread
perception among folks on the left
that donald trump is as the satanic
incredibly evil figure that if trump
goes away everything in the united
states gets better
that if trump goes away then we have
this great
coming together covid ends the skies
shine forth the beautiful new sun
not true there are grave underlying
issues these issues predated trump
frankly the country in terms of social
comedy
in terms in terms of the social fabric
the con the country was much better off
in
at the very beginning of 2009 right
after obama was elected but before
obama actually became who he became over
the course of his terms
and the the the problems that have been
ripping america apart during the trump
era did not start during the trump year
they started during the obama era the
trump era was largely a response
to them and they're not going to go away
if trump goes away
this is why you're seeing the kind of
violence that you are seeing against
trump supporters
again if this were violence against
biden supporters by trump supporters you
know it would be front page news it is
not therefore it is not
this happened this was an altercation
that happened
in san francisco there's a black man in
san francisco
who's protecting people who are marching
for trump
from presumably members of antifa uh
and other violent protesters uh and um
and this guy got his front teeth knocked
out
here's a little bit of video of the
incident
[Music]
i mean the guy's literally just standing
there and they're trying to walk away
and these
these jackasses in black masks come up
to them and just start punching them
directly in the face
i mean that that's absurd it's absurd
how is this acceptable in civil society
the answer is it's not
but when you say it's okay to punch a
nazi and then you define everybody you
don't like is a nazi it becomes very
easy for this to happen meanwhile
reportedly in washington dc this is
according to the post-millennial a
female trump supporter was allegedly
attacked and hospitalized
by women's march and black lives matter
activists after she participated
in a pro-trump rally isabella maria
deluca whose bio identifies her as a
turning point usa ambassador posted
images of her injuries while recovering
at a local hospital
apparently she is outreach director for
the republicans for national renewal
which is a pro-trump organization
a breitbart news reporter attending the
event captured footage of deluca waving
a trump flag and shouting four more
years earlier
in the day deluca says that she was
assaulted by an older female she said
the first woman was a white older woman
she had glasses on a glittery bedazzle
black lives matter
shirt she like she could have been my
grandma honestly according to deluca a
younger assailant then grabbed luca's
pro-trump flag when she tried to grab it
back to woman allegedly punched and
choked her
deluca said she felt reluctant to defend
herself due to the advanced age of her
attacker but was determined to retrieve
the flag when it was snatched deluca
told the publication a younger female
black lives matter supporter assisted
the older woman who had initially
assaulted her by hitting pushing
and punching de luca apparently she was
treated with a cervical collar due to
her to her head
and neck injuries and said she was
suffering from blurry vision and
dizziness
due to the impact and we've seen this
sort of stuff fairly routinely across
the country
you know people who are wearing maga
hats and this is treated as though they
are wearing a swastika on their hats
and therefore people are being punched
and
honestly the mainstream left may not be
in favor of the violence but they're
certainly in favor of this basic idea
which is that if you vote for trump
if you consider voting for trump you are
evil it's one of the reasons why i think
the left is so fearful about the polling
right now
because when you castigate anybody who
possibly would vote for trump as an
emissary of satan
it turns out they stopped telling
pollsters that they're going to vote for
trump and so there is this great fear
out there that there's this enormous
silent trump vote now that may or may
not be true it would have to be
incredibly enormous to overcome the sort
of barriers to election that trump is
showing in the polls right now the polls
are narrowing just slightly there's an
ibd tippy poll today out
showing that trump is down six
nationally if trump gets down to about
down four nationally then this starts to
look like a very very competitive race
again
and indeed the gap has started to narrow
a little bit that's not a shock it
usually does
in the very lead up to the election but
the kind of language that is used by
typical mainstream members of the left
is indicative of their thought process
when it comes to
how trump supporters are to be viewed
and it is specifically because of that
that i think trump has such a high level
of support among republicans among other
reasons
which is if you suggest that everybody
who supports conservative viewpoints
is the equivalent of president trump
like they treated romney and they
treated trump
kind of the same way and so a lot of
republicans really resonate to the trump
line it's not about me it's about you
right the reason they don't hate me they
don't they don't hate you because they
hate me they hate me because they hate
you
right i am just a stand-in for their
hatred of you i'm just the
the face that they put on their hatred
of you many americans who disagree with
the wild left agenda
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content